nous avons exprès le détour par annoncer
nous voulions aller à travaux
directement pour montrer à nos amis la
place stanislas et ses vieux souvenirs
veille alors nous déplorons un peu de
voir ici et ses boiseries ces ferrailles
qui ne sont vraiment pas esthétique sur
une place pour celle ci monsieur que
pensez vous de la place stanislas est
elle belle hausse est très belle là bas
elle est belle s'est achevée jeunes car
c'est dommage que l'investiture qui sont
venus feu la place stanislas et pâques
le cieux sans frontières même que pensez
vous de la place stanislas dans son état
actuel
et vous qu'en pensez vous mesdames
c'est très dommage après moi j'ai connu
la place stanislas il ya une dizaine
d'années or venez voir la place
maintenant c'est très dommage que ça
soit occupé par les jeux
intervilles hamas est une émission assez
suivi je crois à la télévision parle en
belgique on suit ça très fort mais je
trouve dommage que le cachet de la nasa
lisjak soit ainsi amochée par des
constructions pas des barres de fer on
ne retrouve plus le cacher d'entendre
wenger frontières je crois que ce ne
serait pas très raisonnable très adroit
de la part d'une municipalité quand on
pense que toutes les villes de france
souhaite cette émission à l'organiser
qu'il soit y aller ce qu'une fois mais
seulement une fois par an en france
quant à décevoir quelques milliers c'est
peut être beaucoup enfin décevoir des
touristes c'est bien certain mais que
voulez vous il ya toujours un moment où
il faut faire un choix surtout dans la
publicité parce que c'est une opération
publicitaire pour la vie de nancy
puisque cela représenterait ne serait ce
que pour l'eurovision et là je parle à
des gens de métier plus de 90 millions
de téléspectateurs les nancéiens vous
reproche l'implantation de ces jeux sont
mondiales n'y avait-il pas moyen de
trouver un terrain d'entente est
implantée cette arène sur une autre
place la place carrière par exemple à ce
moment là la nuisance qu'était la même
place carrière l'implanter à la
pépinière place cardo sanam n'a
absolument rien à la ville on voyait les
frondaisons d'investisseurs à pouvoir à
90 millions de téléspectateurs porter la
fontaine de neptune l'hôtel de ville
avait peut-être la nuisance des grades
améliorer comme il y aura cinq mille
personnes pour les cachets reverra pas